on behalf of the Arnold a Saltzman
institute award Peace Studies I welcome
you to our retrospective on decade after
September 11 a set of perspectives on
the subject it defines the engagement
terrorism and then like this one might
suspect some risk of dwelling on issues
and ideas that have been discussed to
death over the course of the past 10
years we don't intend to do that this
morning rather we hope to shed light on
some novel topics as well as those whose
salience is well recognized among
organizations at Columbia the Saltzman
Institute i think is ideally chartered
and positioned to reflect on this
subject on the institute houses
researchers who investigate all sorts of
political violence it means of
preventing or coping with it as will
become clear this morning are people
done quite very work on terrorism and
issues related to it you'll hear about
some of the things that have preoccupied
policymakers and commentators in this
country but you'll also hear some things
that are less familiar about selected
aspects of terrorism around the world
that get less constant attention here
but that are quite important the ratio
of new perspectives of the familiar ones
and what's discussed today should prove
to be high I won't waste much more time
droning on about the solemnity of the
occasion with the importance of the
subject I'll suggest though that there
are two mistakes often made about that
question of the importance of terrorism
to overestimate it and to underestimate
it before September 11 it was
underestimated in the year before the
attacks I served as a member of the
National Commission on terrorism
established by Congress and our report
made a number of recommendations for
reducing the odds
attack but the recommendations like
those of most national commissions were
not implemented because of the
inconvenience that cause political
inertia and especially because the
insufficient salience of the threat as
it was perceived at the time after
September 11th the importance of
terrorism came to be overestimated if
one thinks in terms of cold statistics
of actual damage done by terrorists over
time compared to other forms of
political violence the psychological
impact of terrorism has usually exceeded
its material impact although the
casualty toll on sep tember 11th the
highest in an act of war for the United
States I think since the Battle of
Antietam blurred that distinction the
limitations of terrorist action since
sep tember 11th and the passage of time
of dull bat psychological impact a bit
so we may be sliding back toward
underestimation in any case terrorism
remains a significant problem in
different forms in many places
throughout the world in ways that
Americans don't always appreciate so
today you'll hear about some of those
issues and then you'll have a chance to
discuss your questions with the
panelists and to get us underway I turn
the reins over to the panel chair
professor Tanya Putnam who's an expert
on matters generally not well respected
by terrorists international law all
right thank you very much so you all
should have a program on your chair as
you can see kind of how the order of
things that's going to go we have five
presentations today we'll do the first
three and then we'll have a short
10-minute break in between so each
person is going to talk i'll introduce
them as they go we'd like you to save up
all your questions towards the end and
after we've gone through all five
presentations will have an hour hour and
a half to actually have a discussion
about what we hear today so with that
we'll start with dr. Stuart Gottlieb he
is an adjunct
sir of International and public affairs
at at ciba here and also an affiliate of
the salesman Institute at Columbia dr.
Gottlieb holds a teaching position at
New York University also so he gets
around he's involved in everything prior
to joining sefa in 2003 he worked for
nearly five years in the US Senate first
as a senior foreign policy advisor to
Senator Charles Schumer of New York and
also subsequently as a policy adviser
and chief speechwriter for senator
christopher dodd of connecticut dr.
Gottlieb has also worked on several
political campaigns including the new
york city reelection campaign for mayor
Giuliani and also was his advisor on
terrorism related matters in his bid for
the for the presidency in 2008 his
publications include an edited volume
prominently an edited volume called
debating terrorism and counterterrorism
causes context and responses which was
published in 2010 by CQ press so
thanks for coming today braving the
latest terrorist warnings so we're at
the 10th anniversary of 911 and this
anniversary offers a moment not only for
assessment assessment of all that has
occurred as the aptly introduced all
that has occurred over the past decade
but also offers an opportunity for
reflection so I'd like to begin with a
brief personal experience from the day
of the 911 attacks which I believe
offers insights into the topic of my
talk today which is on terror threats
and policy responses since 911 on nine
eleven 2001 as Tanya pointed out I was
working in Washington as a foreign
affairs and national security advisor
for New York senator I've been there for
about three years at that point and I
think everyone in this room recognizes
that like the assassination of John F
Kennedy is set a generation earlier
every one of the present generation
remembers where they were when the twin
towers were hit and when they felt I was
driving to work at around eight thirty
in the morning listening to national
public radio as usual and I heard that a
small plane had struck with north tower
of the world trade center and what was
being called an accident at that point
sounded odd to me I felt little of it
until as I was pulling into the garage
of the Hart building on capitol hill
around nine o'clock I heard that a
second plane struck the second tower and
if these were not small planes these
were now commercial airliners when I
heard that I knew this was a major
terrorist attack most likely originating
from overseas I recall pulling into my
parking space turning off the radio and
I literally SAT there for about 10
minutes pondering not only was waiting
for me sorry emotional day
what was waiting to me when I walked
into the office that day which was out
to you a lot but also how much my life
and the lives of all Americans and
millions more around the world we're
going to change in countless and
unforeseen ways the months and years to
come I don't have enough time to go into
all the sorrel of events that I make me
so emotional I watched a lot of friends
that day in New York and a lot of stuff
was going on down in DC but many other
people in the room have experienced a
lot of things but let me just give a few
of my quick experiences that I think it
could highlight the direction I want to
go with my talk we learned early on that
it was Al Qaeda from passenger manifests
and intelligence cross lists I was
actually one of the first people to know
to know that I bumped into a friend of
mine who worked for Tom Daschle who is
the majority leader in the Senate at the
time and he told me and I guess it's
safe to say now that I was one of the
sources that tipped off CNN who broke
the story that it was Al Qaeda um we
were briefed the next morning that there
was a near certainty of major follow-on
attacks in the coming weeks and months
possibly with the use of weapons of mass
destruction and that turned out to be
accurate we know after jose padilla an
american citizen was arrested in early
2002 that there was a follow-on attack
radiological bomb attack that was
disrupted almost immediately after the
attack almost immediately after the
attack occurred the attack was being
blamed on a dearth of so-called human
intelligence congressmen and
Congresswomen of both parties and all
ideological stripes were demanding to
know why human intelligence gathering
and operations especially from places
like the CIA's special Activities
Division were allowed to degrade to the
degree that they did in the 1990s and
how these human intelligence
capabilities could swiftly be
revitalized the bottom line is the
landscape of threat perception regarding
terrorism and deliberations over policy
responses change seemingly in an instant
policies that were unimaginable just one
day earlier on September 10
2001 became no-brainers and swiftly
passed Congress or became part of
emergency presidential executive orders
two pieces of legislation that I was
working on pre 911 one was a bill to
ease pfizer requirements for certain
that's Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act requirements for certain Fourth
Amendment wiretaps and a second bill
concerned the tracking of bank fraud and
money laundering both were going nowhere
before September 11 2001 be honest with
you and both or concept of them swiftly
became parts of policy one as part of
the Patriot Act and the other as part of
an executive order on terror financing
and money laundering multiply those two
provisions by dozens and dozens of
others and dozens and dozens more that
no one had even yet thought up prior to
911 and you get a sense of a swirl of
policy activity in the days and weeks
after 911 it was easily one of the most
monumental shifts and policy in the
nation's history right up there with NSC
68 and the creation of NATO in the early
days of the Cold War to give you an idea
I have some numbers within four months
of the 911 attacks President Bush had
public publicly issued 22 presidential
executive orders related to 911 and that
does not include the dozens of secret
executive orders that were coming down
and more than two dozen new measures
proposed to congress by the
administration had already become ball
within four months now think how long it
took president obama to pass one law the
health care law these congressional
measures at the time included the sep
tember 18th joint resolution of congress
authorized in the president nited states
to quote use all necessary and
appropriate force unquote against those
who committed or a to the 911 attacks
and in order to and this is an often
overlooked provision and in order to
quote prevent any future attacks of
terrorism against the united states
unquote that's an important final
applause than the preventive clause I'm
going to get back to that in a minute
also among the big measures was passage
of the USA PATRIOT Act which went well
beyond the minor FISA bill that I was
working on the Patriot Act was by far
the most significant domestic
counterterrorism law since the passage
of FISA in 1978 it significantly lowered
the threshold for anti-terrorism
surveillance and the US and in the
United States and it dismantled much of
the the so-called firewall between
domestic and international intelligence
gathering and between intelligence
agencies and law enforcement agencies
one more general word on the immediate
aftermath of the attacks something that
has stuck with me something I found very
disconcerting that was the ease with
which Congress in particular and the
country in general was willing to cede
nearly all Power Authority and
responsibility to the executive branch
in the aftermath of 911 in fact it would
not be until June of 2004 more than a
full two and a half years after nine
eleven attacks before the Supreme Court
of United States would offer its first
ruling on the constitutionality of key
aspects of the Bush administration
so-called war on terrorism and it would
be longer still before Congress took any
active role in overseeing or partaking
in counterterrorism policy making a
years later we watched many of the more
aggressive Bush policies such as
coercive interrogations secret prisons
and definite detentions warrantless
wiretapping we saw all of these
eventually become political hot button
issues and I emphasize years later but
the fact is many of the very same
latter-day critics including in the
Democratic leadership were fully
informed of the bush policies and in
some cases in the weeks and months after
nine eleven were pushing the
administration and the CA to make sure
that what they were doing was enough and
that they were quote acting aggressively
enough unquote to quote one unnamed
leader so with that as contextual
background let me briefly mention a few
fundamental changes in the way terror
threats have been perceived since 911
and in the response to terrorism since
then we obviously don't have enough time
to get into all aspects of the
dramatically changed landscape of
terrorism and counterterrorism since
nine eleven but in my view we do not
need to delve too much into the detail
in order to understand some of the
fundamental changes that's because there
have been what I would call two big
macro changes in firstly our assessment
of the nature of terror threats and
secondly in our response to the threats
the first big macro change was the altar
threat landscape or more accurately
altered perceptions of the threat
landscape one of the most enduring
aspects of the 911 attack was that it
instantly undercut long-standing
mainstream perceptions of the nature of
terrorist threats for generations
terrorism was most often understood as a
tactic used by groups to gain attention
for the particular costs with the use of
violence even killing understood as
somewhat rational or at least limited as
longtime terrorism analyst Brian Jenkins
famously said in his classic description
of terrorism he said terrorists want
quote a lot of people watching not a lot
of people dead unquote and that was
certainly true for a whole variety of
so-called traditional terrorist groups
at the time like the Irish Republican
Army or the Popular Front for the
Liberation of Palestine or the Basque
separatist group in Spain Etta these
were groups that were open to or even
seeking eventual seats at the
negotiating table on 911 this
traditional understanding of terrorism
was thrown a major curveball what the
United States in the world confronted on
911 was not a terror group seeking a
seat at the negotiating table it was a
terror group seeking to blow up the
negotiating table everyone around it and
possibly even themselves this was
something very new and very dangerous
and as seen ten years ago this week very
capable on 911 a new template of
terrorism had come of age
religious-based terrorism with a
powerful global narrative and a violent
global vision operating independently of
any formal state support and with no
limitations on casualties in fact the
more casualties the better there are
differences of opinion over just how new
or how non-negotiable this form of
terrorism really is and others on the
panel may point that out today but
there's no denying that on 911 we
witnessed up close the handiwork of a
dangerous new terrorist act during
very international affairs and there's
no denying that preventing future
attacks by Al Qaeda and its affiliates
or some other similarly inspired group
remains the number one priority of not
just the United States government but
dozens of governments all around the
world as we see this morning with the
latest credible terror alert al Qaeda
even with its core in Pakistan
Afghanistan weakened remains today the
most likely source of another major
attack particularly the evolving problem
would be its inspired or affiliated
groups gaining strength in other parts
of South and Central Asia North and East
Africa the Arabian Peninsula and
elsewhere with that let me let me
briefly say a few words on the second
macro change since nine eleven change in
the guiding principles that underpin
policy responses to terrorism at least
in the United States much of this change
obviously relates to the new assessment
of the terror threat as I just described
the best way to summarize this change
and all of the sometimes controversial
policies that flow from it is to say
that prior to nine eleven the United
States essentially treated terrorism as
a criminal act with terrorists and
suspected terrorists afforded full
judicial rights and with strict
limitations placed on the government's
ability to engage in what we can think
of as preventive action such as
detaining someone without any evidence
that they actually committed a crime
after nine eleven the United States
swiftly moved away from the law
enforcement model and counterterrorism
and and toward what can best be
described as a warfare model which
treats terrorism at least in the guise
of al Qaeda and its affiliates as a
revolutionary form of warfare requiring
a broader national security rather than
primarily law enforcement response
particularly in an age of catastrophic
terrorism the argument goes simply
responding to terrorist events after
they occur with criminal indictments and
prosecutions is not sufficient the goal
must be to prevent attacks from
occurring in the first place and that
requires a far greater use of national
presidential commander-in-chief powers
everyone here today is I'm sure familiar
with the policy outgrowth from this
shift in America's macro approach to
fighting terrorism the so-called
preventive paradigm as it emerged from
the sep tember 18th 2001 congressional
authorization laid the foundations for
the Patriot Act National Security Agency
warrantless wiretapping renditions
coercive interrogations indefinite
detentions targeted assassinations and
all sorts of covert operations in dozens
of countries overseas all in the name of
stopping the next attack but let me
point out a most important point that I
want to conclude with that while this
approach may have been born during the
bush-cheney administration it remains
alive and well under the Obama
administration despite Obama's many
promises during the campaign to quote
unquote reverse Bush's counterterrorism
policies and despite occasional symbolic
gestures like efforts to close
Guantanamo or try high-profile
terrorists in a civilian court the fact
is Obama has maintained and in some
cases even bolstered many of the Bush
administration's most aggressive and
controversial policies including
renditions targeted assassinations
indefinite detentions warrantless
searches and wiretaps and a dick cheney
esque interpretation of executive power
when it comes to withholding information
under the so-called state secrets
doctrine and that leads me to my final
concluding thought about where the
United States currently stands in terms
of terror threats and responses now ten
years after the 911 attacks and where we
may be heading I would make the case
that the two macro changes that I
pointed out in the assessment of terror
threats and in the legal and national
security parameters that now guide
anti-terror policymaking that these two
macro changes have sparked an evolution
over the course of the past ten years
and over the and over the terms of two
presidencies to form what can be thought
of for better or worse and we could have
some discussion on that at some point
but it's formed a sort of bipartisan
counterterrorism consensus
that's emerging this rough but evolving
consensus begins with a recognition that
al-qaida and its affiliates form a
unique national security threat
requiring a national security response
and for this rough but evolving
consensus that response includes three
core components at each of those
components is controversial in its own
right those core components are number
one recognition of the necessity of
strong executive powers and presidential
freedom of action number two the
critical role of aggressive intelligence
gathering to level the playing field
with sophisticated mass casualty
terrorists that operate in the shadows
and number three reliance on military
operations and covert actions to target
terrorists and preempt terrorists
planning and operations from abroad
these policy foundations were built
under bush but institutionalized under
Obama not unlike the way Democratic
president harry truman's been
controversial containment policy was
eventually institutionalized by
Republican presidential Republican
President Dwight Eisenhower in the 1950s
I should also add that along with these
are talking about mostly hard power you
know policies here but I should at least
add that along with these hard power
components of this evolving
counterterrorism consensus also exists
various softer tower components to try
to ideologically challenge al-qaeda and
you know win hearts and minds of
potential recruits I'm not surprisingly
Bush and Obama had somewhat different
ways of going about this but i will say
that in both cases the soft power hearts
and mind stuff has taken a big back seat
to the more hard power approaches which
gives you a sense of the continuity of
threat assessment from Bush to Obama and
I will finish by saying as long as this
threat assessment remains and front
remains we can expect further evolution
and refinement of this evolving
counterterrorism model and we should
also hope further oversight or increased
oversight and more candor from
government leaders
on this on this challenge that will
continue for the foreseeable future and
I'll conclude on one point to continue
dick said that are the biggest change or
the biggest challenge is is a
overestimating or underestimated the
threat of terrorism and with that comes
a secondary challenge which is which is
the challenge of overreaction versus
under reaction and within this the
context of this of this new policy
structure exists political wherewithal
or more flexibility on how it responds
or how it doesn't respond and we going
to continue have to find a middle ground
because overreaction plays right into
the hands of those who want to continue
this this war against us but under
reaction unfortunately and eliminating
some of these tools that I just
mentioned that have continued from
bushed Obama's controversial as they may
be a sense of complacency or a new in
the New York in the Washington Post
Eugene Robinson wrote today that we've
already defeated al Qaeda so why do we
still have these policies that's that
could lead to an under reaction could
that could be just as dangerous because
it's going to just take one more attack
even by a lone actor you know it's Dick
pointed out that could get this whole
cycle of overreaction going again which
would play right into the hands of those
who want to keep this fight going for
the next generation and I'm done for now
and I'll turn it back over
thank you very much dr. Gottlieb next we
have professor Kimberley Martin so
Professor Martin she's a she's professor
of political science and a former
department chair at Barnard College and
she's also a member of the salesman
Institute at Columbia her fourth book is
about to come out entitled warlords
strong-armed brokers in weak states
that'll be out in May 2012 from the
Cornell University Press series on
studies and security affairs her new
research project has to do with non
state militias and it asks whether and
how patronage based forces can be
transformed into in personal and
professional military and police
organizations so again really
interesting stuff today she's going to
talk to us about what social scientists
think they've learned about terrorism
and terrorists thank you thanks Tanya
like Stuart I was personally affected by
September 11th I was in New York when it
happened I went through the shock and
the fear and sadness that I'm sure many
of us in the audience did I went to the
funerals I comforted friends who had
suffered losses and then you may
remember that what happened immediately
after September 11th was the anthrax
attacks that came through the US mail
and I lived in New Jersey at that time
and it seemed that New Jersey was being
particularly targeted by those anthrax
attacks and so that just added to the
fear and I think the low point for me
was one day when I was commuting in
there was an armored personnel carrier
guarding the lincoln tunnel and that
summed it up more than anything else so
the way i eventually processed my fear
was by starting to teach a new class on
political violence and terrorism at
Barnard I decided that I wanted to learn
what caused terrorism and what that
meant about how we should react to
terrorism to prevent it from happening
and I wanted my students to be exposed
to really good evidence and really good
scholarship about terrorism because
there was so much hyperbola and so many
people who really didn't know what they
were talking about saying things in the
news that I thought it was time that we
put something together that allowed
really good research on terrorism to
come to the forefront and the class got
easier to teach with
time because there's been a huge influx
of new scholarship on the topic of what
causes terrorism and what that means
about counter terrorist activities and
so that's what I want to talk to you
about today there's a consensus about
social among social scientists that we
don't want to use the word terrorists
because if we use the word terrorists it
implies that people are always going to
commit acts of terrorism and that there
is a particular individual who has a
terrorist personality or something like
that instead rather than defining
individuals as terrorists we tend to
talk about acts of terrorism terrorism
as opposed to some other tactic of
political action so that's my starting
point and I think it's important also
that we have a common definition of what
terrorism is and here again there's a
fair amount of agreement among social
scientists i'll talk about one exception
as i go along but there's a fair amount
of agreement that terrorism involves
acts of violence by non-state actors
against non-combatants for political
purposes in other words we know that
states commit acts of violence against
civilians but that's not really what we
want to talk about when we talk about
terrorism in particular and there's some
disagreement about whether to include
military targets in our target
assessment of what terrorism is but most
people concentrate on acts of violence
against non-combatants against civilians
or people who are not actively involved
in infighting we know that there are non
state actors who commit violence for non
political purposes the best example is
Amish Amriki Oh in Tokyo its purpose was
to bring on the apocalypse and so that's
not an act of politics but I would
disagree a little bit with Stuart I
think that in fact al Qaeda is carrying
out acts of terrorism for political
purposes so what do we know about what
causes terrorism well we know what
doesn't cause terrorism we know now what
we didn't know so much in 2001 that
terrorism is not caused by a lack of
Economic Opportunity or a lack of
educational opportunity if any of you
were involved in the policy discussions
immediately after September 11 that was
just a real big thing that every
II was saying we have to give more
international assistance we have to
provide education to people abroad and
that'll stop terrorism but Alan Krueger
who is the new who is an economist at
Princeton and he is the new chairman of
the Council of Economic Advisers that
Obama has nominated did a major study
it's been also seconded by other major
political scientists and economists
including David Leighton at Stanford
University looking at reims across
national data that the vast majority of
people who commit terrorist acts are
well-educated there in the middle to
upper class and so they're not they're
not poor this actually fits with earlier
data by area experts we knew that the
leaders of Marxist political violence in
Russia China Central and South America
during the Cold War and before the Cold
War were more likely to be scholars than
they were to be workers we also know
that scholars led some of the most
horrific acts of violence against
civilians in both the former Yugoslavia
and the post-soviet space including
Georgia Krueger also demonstrated that
wealthier countries produce more acts of
terrorism than poorer countries do and
that economic equality inequality inside
a society didn't seem to correlate to
terrorist acts so there's just no
statistical relationship between poverty
or lack of education and either the
commission of terrorist acts or societal
support for terrorist acts and that's
really significant because that means
that terrorism is caused by factors that
are different from the causes of other
political violence Paul Collier at
Oxford University who's an economist did
research at the World Bank that
demonstrated that political violence in
society civil war is correlated with
economic inequality but acts of
terrorism and support for terrorism do
not seem to be correlated with economic
inequality so what does cause terrorism
well scholars tend to divide the
societal level from the leader level and
so what do we know about the societal
level if you think about it the people
who commit and support acts of terrorism
are really different from each other
they're the people who actually commit
the acts they're the people who plan the
acts who are maybe at a higher level
than the foot soldiers and then they're
the citizens who tolerate terrorism and
don't turn perpetrators or suspects
to the police who instead think that
terrorism is an okay thing well there's
overwhelming evidence again from Kruger
that societies that spawned terrorism
societies where the population seems to
support terrorism rather than turning
people who commit terrorist acts into
the government suffer from political
inequality and a lack of political
opportunity so acts of terrorism don't
seem to be associated with economic
inequality but they do seem to be
associated with a political inequality
and the lack of political opportunity
the majority of terrorist acts appear to
be committed by people who believe that
they live in a politically unjust
society where they have no chance to
make a difference through nonviolent
action so that's the first thing we know
the second thing we know is that the
vast majority of terrorism is local so
the September 11th attacks and the
al-qaeda attacks that followed in
various places around the world were
rare in not being carried out in the
same country where the perpetrators were
located al-qaeda is an exception it's
not the wave of the future Martha
Crenshaw had been talking about that
even before the al-qaeda attacks
happened she's a Stanford professor now
who's been writing on terrorism since
1972 but now others have started
demonstrating that fact with cross
national data and so again Krueger
demonstrated that ninety percent of
terrorist attacks have occurred in the
country where the perpetrator lives
ninety percent well what does this mean
how can we explain September 11th in
al-qaeda it may mean that the real
target was their home countries those
were countries who were allied with the
United States but the societies were so
closed and so repressive and such police
states that there was no way for them to
reasonably get away with the terrorist
attack in those societies and so it may
have been easier to attack the United
States as an open society and as an ally
of those societies rather than
committing the acts at home and Martha
Crenshaw was again the first person to
make that argument so that's a second
thing that we know that most terrorism
is local a third argument that has
provoked some controversy but that seems
to have a fair amount of truth behind it
is that terrorism may
be in rien relation in reaction to what
is perceived as a foreign occupation if
this is true what matters is not having
alliances with particular countries per
se but having a military presence abroad
that's associated with those alliances
so the argument here is that the US
bases in Saudi Arabia at the time of the
September 11th attacks meant that the
infidels were in Mecca and Medina and
from this point the United States kept
on making things worse by sending large
numbers of ground troops into Iraq and
Afghanistan where they were perceived as
occupiers and this argument is most
associated with Robert Pape a professor
at the University of Chicago who founded
the University of Chicago project on
suicide terrorism his major explanation
for suicide terrorism again using just
reams of cross national data if the
presence of resented foreign military
forces on home territory and he argued
that democracies were particularly
susceptible to terrorist attack because
terrorists understood that their
public's would respond to attacks and
demand an exit of those military troops
from the places where they were abroad
now many scholars have poked holes into
his logic and his evidence he's been
criticized for focused on for focusing
only on suicide terrorism which is
actually not the most common form of
terrorism even though it's the kind that
gets a lot of attention in the media
it's a small fraction of terrorist acts
it also he has been criticized for
getting back to our original definition
for including attacks on military
targets not just attacks on civilian
targets but his arguments have had real
policy impact perhaps because the
arguments fit in with those who believed
that the United States should have a
smaller military footprint in foreign
countries to decrease the military
presence of the United States abroad it
certainly helps explain the u.s.
reluctance to get involved in Libya on
the ground and it also explains probably
are increasing desire to have only a
very small number of special operations
forces on the ground in places like Iraq
and Afghanistan and to pull out the
large number of forces who had a large
footprint so that's about societal
support for terrorism y de leader
support terrorism
as opposed to some other form of
political action well there's agreement
among virtually all analysts including
Martha Crenshaw Bruce Hoffman who's also
been staring studying terrorism for
decades Andrew kid and Barbara Walter as
well as Robert tape that acts of
terrorism are carried out by weak actors
who cannot afford direct military attack
suicide bombing in particular is a very
low-cost act of violence it doesn't take
much to put a bomb on somebody and have
them go blow up things and get a lot of
attention for it so terrorism is seen as
being politically strategic it may be
designed to persuade some audience to
take political actions by making them
believe that otherwise the pain will
continue and so in political science
jargon terms we could say that for in
that sense it's a form of credible
signaling of political intentions and a
future actions that basically if you
don't stop what you're doing we're going
to continue attacking you and we know
that sometimes acts of terrorist
violence work the u.s. withdrew withdrew
from Lebanon after the Marines barracks
were attacked the u.s. withdrew from
Saudi Arabia after September 11th
largely because of the kind of argument
that people like Robert Pape made Spain
withdrew from the Iraq coalition because
of the 2004 Madrid bombing it probably
affected the election there and the
policies of the new government so
sometimes acts of political terrorism do
work to have political impact and what
this means for counterterrorism strategy
is that if this is true the counter
isn't counterterrorism strategy has to
be very carefully calibrated to the
specific aims of the people who are
carrying out the acts of terrorism so as
Stewart pointed out sometimes
negotiation with terrorists actually
works if it involves giving in on
something that has low strategic
importance but if it's something that
has high strategic importance something
that that would be vital to a country's
interests that means that negotiating
with the terrorists doesn't make any
sense at all and instead what you do is
have to put up a very strong front
showing that those acts of terrorism
will
not change the political action that
they are designed to change an odd rae
carruth Cronin who's at the National War
College argued in 2006 that this fact
meant that al Qaeda's end was inevitable
that it would rapidly come to a
conclusion because the goal that
al-qaeda seemed to want the political
goal that al-qaeda was following
establishing a Caliphate over the entire
Islamic world was unreachable without
international revolution and the tactics
that they used suicide bombing and
attacks against innocent Muslims were
horrifying the audience that they wish
to appeal to and this was actually
supported by Ronen Bergman and Israeli
journalist in September 2008 who
demonstrated that by following what was
happening on al-qaeda websites that
al-qaeda was turning away from urging
suicide attacks and turning towards
urging people to instead commit acts of
terrorism using high-tech remote bombs
the best evidence in fact that Cronin
may be right and I think this is a very
hopeful sign is that the Arab Spring has
not been hijacked by al-qaeda you have
people coming from societies of
political repression political
inequality and you don't see them saying
so the reaction that we should be taking
is to turn towards terrorism al-qaeda
has essentially been irrelevant in the
Arab Spring and I think that's a very
positive sign that adres Cronin was
correct a second thing that terrorist
attacks might be intended to do though
is to send a signal internally to the
group that might support the group in
its home society a signal that the group
is still functioning cohesively and that
it is politically beneficial to continue
to support that group so mark Jergens
Meyers sociologist at UC Santa Barbara
says that the fact that they're being an
internal audience explains why
responsibility is not always claimed for
acts of terrorism the internal audience
knows who did it and doesn't have to be
told it can actually be an act of
political outfitting to a larger
domestic audience where there are
political competitors saying look how
strong we are come and support us
instead of our competitors because we
can still carry out these very very
violent attacks so Bruce Hoffman and
Gordon McCormack showed that in both Sri
Lanka and palace
terrorist acts increased every time the
moderate opposition looked like they
were doing well it was outbidding it was
saying don't go with the moderate
opposition go with us were the ones who
have the power and the strength to
actually create change so when this is
combined with the earlier conclusion
about political repression being
associated with increased terrorism it
means that probably the most effective
counterterrorism policy demonstrates
that the state is stronger than the
terrorists without engaging in
repression so that's obviously very
challenging how can you show that you
are a strong state without engaging in
acts of political repression the trick
is to get the community to turn toward
the state away from the terrorists and
to leave the terrorists isolated and a
journalist named Ed Maloney in his book
on the Irish Republican Army
demonstrated that in fact this was wise
the United Kingdom was so successful in
tamping down the IRA when they had a
policy of randomly imprisoning young
people on the street who were suspected
of terrorism and holding them for a long
period of time it actually made acts of
terrorism go up when they were
successful at getting intelligence on
turning people at the top towards the
states away from acts of terrorism and
stopping things that were perceived as
being societal repressed with society
repressive acts of terrorism went down
and the IRA became a political group
instead so the final question I want to
look at is what turns people away from
being passive victims of perceived
repression or supporters of some other
form of revolution into being active
supporters of terrorism how do we
explain how societies go towards a
situation where they are supporting acts
of terrorism and there seems to be
agreement here among social scientists
as well that the interesting conclusion
is it's their friends and other social
connections it's not mental illness
there's a popular perception that
terrorists are all crazy but there is no
evidence of high levels of mental
illness among the detailed records of
suicide bombers for example that have
been collected at the University of
Chicago project this was emphasized by
Lindsay Oh work a graduate student in
that project who's written about female
suicide bombers in particular there's no
evidence of higher levels of mental
illness among the people who choose to
be suicide bombers the idea of support
for terrorism being related to social
networks with
was proposed by james coleman a
sociologist at the university of chicago
in 1988 and he argued again this has
started from a technical perspective and
I apologize for throwing out this jargon
that social encouragement is how the
free rider problem is overcome in groups
to create an impetus for costly
collective action in other words if you
have a group of people that natural
tendency is to stand back and say let
somebody else do it I don't have to take
the risk of that behavior and the way
that you get a group to be revved up to
actually take an action that is
personally costly to individual members
is through social encouragement this was
seconded by a major theorist of civil
uprising behavior Roger Peterson of MIT
also who got his graduate work at the
University of Chicago there's a pattern
here it was found in his study of
Lithuanian rebel movements in the 1940s
and he showed that how you acted toward
the occupier depended on your social
networks and what your close associates
did mark sage Minh one of the first
network of analysts for the CIA during
the Afghanistan conflict back in the
1980s famously argued in leaderless
jihad a book that provoked a lot of
controversy that international terrorism
was both unstoppable but less
threatening as the decade went by
because it was being propelled by social
connections on the internet among people
who had minimal training and minimal
resources as al-qaeda was being degraded
and he was being criticized by Bruce
Hoffman for his lack of data Hoffman was
focused on the continuing threat of a
well-organized group argument between
them was made actually in the pages of
the New York Times but despite Hoffman's
criticisms even if you believe that
al-qaeda is still a strong actor at a
political level I think that Marc's age
means arguments have a really strong
impact on how we think about
counterterrorism which is that if you
want to stop people from supporting
terrorism you have to enter their social
networks enter their friendship networks
and get the people who are around them
in their social environment to convince
them that acts of political violence are
not a good idea and that solving
problems through nonviolent action is a
better way to go so summing this all up
the real key to counterterrorism policy
is getting networks of friends and
networks of social supporters to
advocate nonviolent solutions to
problems and in fact some of the most
creative work that's being done in this
direction is
being done in Saudi Arabia there's a
thesis by Amanda Johnson at the Naval
Postgraduate School who argued that
Saudi Arabia is doing a very effective
job of turning people away from
considering acts of violence who are
currently in prison for having committed
or supported acts of terrorism and it's
because their families were brought on
board they had personal mentors who main
contact maintain contact with them after
they were released they were provided
with opportunities and they were in a
supportive network that said it's okay
you don't have to commit acts of
terrorism in order to get ahead in our
society so I'll stop there with what I
hope is some provocative thinking and I
look forward to the discussion later on
thank you next up we have a professor
teenage fortnight well while she's
getting that worked out i will go ahead
and introduce her so um cousin Cora is a
professor of political science at
Columbia University and also a member of
the salesman institute again pattern
here so her research topics in her
broader research topics of included
durability of peace in the aftermath of
both civil wars and interstate wars her
most recent book is called does
peacekeeping work of shaping
belligerence choices after civil war
which was published by princeton
university press in 2008 her current
research continues to focus on long-term
historical trends and warm termination
but it's expanded now to include
terrorism and its role in civil wars so
she'll be talking to us about current
research thing right thanks Diane thanks
everyone for coming and so so Ken's talk
sort of set this one up I think it's a
coincidence but kind of nicely because
what I'm going to be talking about is an
example of my own scholarship on
terrorism using some cross national data
so what I'm going to talk to you about
today is a paper that's part of a larger
project on terrorism in the context of
civil war so domestic terrorism which as
Kim just mentioned is the vast majority
of terrorism and a number of the things
that I will speak to here we'll sort of
echo some of the
things sometimes agree with and
sometimes contradicting with the rest
the sort of general literature and that
Kim has just outlined for us so so
there's a large debate within the
terrorism literature about whether
terrorism is effective whether it works
probably the majority of that literature
thinks the terrorism does work that's
why it's used its strategic etc etc but
there are some folks who are sort of
arguing no it doesn't work so there's
this there's this big literature but
when I started to look at this
literature a little bit I realize
there's a big problem with this debate
and with this literature because almost
all of the studies that look at
terrorism are only looking at terrorist
groups they're not comparing terrorist
groups with something else with some
other type of political action for
example this is a little bit like trying
to decide if a drug is effective in a
medical study when you're giving
everybody the drug and you're not
looking at a comparison category or a
control group so there should have a
basic problem and a basic inability to
answer some of our most basic questions
about effectiveness and so what I'm
trying to do in this project is to look
at civil wars as a set of cases where
there's a relatively comparable
population there are rebel groups in all
of these wars they're all organized they
all have a political grievance against
the state and some of them use terrorism
and some of them Josh and so we can
compare the outcomes of four groups who
use terrorism and groups that junk and
so that's kind of what I'm trying to do
in this larger project and i'll talk
about one piece of it today and so
defining terrorism for the purposes of
this project i'm defining terrorism
fairly narrowly so this is a definition
that fits within the definition that Kim
just gave us but it's a little bit
narrower because all rebel groups are
using political using violence for
political ends and it turns out the
studies of violence against civilians in
civil wars suggest that almost all
virtually all rebel groups target
civilians in some way so I want to look
at a specific type of targeting of
civilians and that's a symbolic and
indiscriminate violence against
civilians and by symbolic I'm using them
this is sort of from the terrorism
literature what that means is that the
audience of the violence is somebody
other than the target of the violence so
groups are targeting civilians generally
in order to put pressure on a government
not to put pressure on those civilians
per se so this distinguishes this type
of violence against civilians from for
example ethnic cleansing where you're
targeting people to try to get them to
get up and move out of territory that
you want or the most common most
ubiquitous form of violence against
civilians in civil wars is targeting
individuals because you think that
they're collaborating with the other
side or you want to deter them from
doing so or you want to force them to
collaborate with your own side that
happens in ninety-nine point nine nine
percent of all civil wars and so in
order to distinguish rebel groups that
use terrorism from those that don't I
don't want to use such a broad
definition that I'm capturing everybody
and so I want to use this more specific
type of terrorism so more concretely
what do I mean by terrorism are
terrorists rebel groups I mean groups
that use a sustained and deliberate use
of small-scale bombs Karan bus bombs IED
suicide bombs to attack public civilian
places restaurants bombs markets etc and
so that's Fitz fairly well with what we
think I've sort of intuitively as a
terrorist attack and if you look at the
set of rebel groups that show up as
terrorists if you you as if you use this
definition and this measurement it fits
pretty well with the groups that we
think of as terrorists rebel groups and
some of the examples are there on the
screen and in terms of thinking about
effectiveness or winning what what do we
mean by that and a lot of the debate
about effectiveness has sort of gotten
into a little bit of a quagmire over
what counts as success and what counts
as failure and I think we can get a rat
away from some of that craig peyer by
thinking of this as a continuum and the
two endpoints of the continuum are
pretty straightforward it's obviously
rebel groups you know what they really
want is to win out
through a military victory and what they
least want is for the government to
crush them through a military defeat and
so those are pretty obvious I argue that
the sort of second best outcome from
rebel groups perspective is a negotiated
agreement so this means that the
government has recognized them as a
legitimate negotiating partner and there
have been concessions on both sides
generally altering the status quo so
there are some political concessions to
the rebel group if there's a negotiated
agreement there's a kind of second worst
outcome from the rebels perspective
these are wars that in the data that I'm
looking at just kind of fizzle out so
the group still exists it hasn't been
eliminated outright otherwise it would
be coded as a military government
military victory but these are groups
that have been causing a lot of trouble
in wars that have been killing over a
thousand people a year and now they've
fizzled down to such a low level that
fewer than 25 people are dying a year
and often they're no deaths in these
cases but the group still exists and
then in the middle I think about ongoing
conflict so these are groups that
continue to survive they haven't you
know so fizzled away or been defeated
but they have not yet achieved any of
their political go so they're sort of in
the middle of this spectrum and so so
what I'm trying to do in this project is
to compare rebel terrorist groups and
rebel mom terrorist groups and see how
they fare along this spectrum that's
kind of the basic idea so I argue that
terrorists will generally be
unsuccessful they will rarely if ever
win outright because on balance
terrorism undermines military effective
effectiveness rebel relative to non
terrorists Robo tactics and I'm not
going to go through all of the reasons
that I think this because I don't have
time but just to sort of skim over a few
of them terrorism is pretty much by
definition not useful for taking and
holding territory or degrading the
opponent's military capacity it is a
low-cost way to inflict a lot of pain in
a war of attrition but it tends to
backfire and it can often be used as a
way to signaling resolve but it tends to
signal weakness so it's not actually a
credible signal of strength and resolve
a sort of a catchword we talk about in
terms of bargaining theories of war it
can help advertise the
the cause but it preaches to the choir
and mostly what it does is undermine
legitimacy and terms of potential
supporters away and even in sort of
strategy of provocation where groups are
committing terrorist attacks in the hope
that the government will then repress
and they'll be a backlash that that
helps them that can work sometimes but
it can also end up just to find a
government cracking down so hard that is
able to defeat a terrorist or rebel
group I also argue that the second best
outcome for rebels is unlikely if
they're using or less likely if they're
using terrorism in part because it
undermines military effectiveness
governments are going to be less likely
to make political concessions to a group
that is less militarily effective than
one that is more militarily effective
and it also undermines trust and creates
commitment problems that makes
negotiated settlement difficult to
achieve governments I think 2a1 have
policies never to negotiate with
terrorists we know that they break those
policies often but the fact that they
have those policies and that rhetoric
makes it even harder for them to
negotiate with a rebel group that uses
terrorism than one fit doesn't on the
other hand I think that terrorism is
kind of good for organizational survival
of rebel groups because Terrace rebels
are hard to defeat out right there
likely just to live a long time and
small organizations can continue to
inflict damage the kinds of spoiling and
outputting dynamics that Kim was talking
about tend to prolong conflicts and
counterterrorism often kind of flattens
out organizations and they and make them
to decentralized so they're not good at
achieving their goals anymore but they
are continuing to launch attacks and I
have sort of a thinking about this
question about the effectiveness of
terrorism some of the debate has been
about effectiveness versus democracies
whether tourism is more effective
against democratic governments than non
democratic governments and I think there
are two reasons to think that it should
be more effective or less ineffective is
paying me a better way to put it against
democracies one is that the basic
strategy here is to put pressure on
civilians or to inflict pain on
civilians so that they'll put pressure
on their government that's going to be
more effective if the civilians can more
effectively put pressure on their
government which is true under democracy
and and it's also more likely that
you'll provoke a government from being
sort of too nice to be in this kind of
in the middle wishy-washy repressing but
not really effectively cracking down
middle ground where a provocation
strategy and backlash can happen whereas
against an autocracy you're more likely
just to justify really draconian
measures and get yourself defeated so
there are a set of predictions that come
out of all of this that civil wars
involving terrorists rebel group should
be longer very unlikely to end in rebel
victory less likely to end in a
negotiated agreement more likely to
fizzle out or end in a government
victory and relatively more effective
versus democracies again all compared to
non terrorists rebel groups and that is
if the world is all else equal but of
course the world is never all else equal
and and so the first thing I have to do
in this project is to think about which
groups use terrorism why are some groups
using terrorism and some not this is a
strategic decision and so terrorism you
know it's it's a random act of violence
but it's not a strategy that has chosen
at random and so the first thing I do in
this project is to look at all of these
rebel groups and this is a post the data
that I have here is from the post-cold
war and about thirty percent of the
groups that I'm looking at in civil wars
in this period are using terrorism and
seventy percent aren't and so drawing on
the Terrorism literature and on the
literature on Civil War I look at a
bunch of things that we might think will
make groups more likely to use terrorism
and a number of the things that I find
kind of fit pretty squarely with the
broader terrorism literature terrorism
is more likely against democratic
governments again remember that this is
these are all just cases where there is
a civil war it's more likely if there's
a religious difference between the rebel
group and the government that it's
fighting more likely in larger or more
populous countries and in richer
countries there's a regional effect that
hasn't been particularly well theorized
that the terrorism is significantly less
likely in civil wars in Africa but that
all sort of fits pretty squarely with
the rest of the literature there are a
few surprising findings that come out of
this and one has to do with secessionist
conflict and this speaks to Bob pates
argument about terrors
versus foreign occupiers unlike what
paper would predict I actually find that
terrorism is significantly less likely
in secessionist conflicts than in non
secessionist complex it's that I'd sort
of threw in religion because this isn't
really conventional wisdom in the
academic literature but the conventional
wisdom kind of on the street that is the
terrorism is associated with Islam
there's absolutely no evidence for this
in fact if anything Islamic groups are
somewhat less likely to use terrorism
than non islamic rebel groups or
non-muslim rebel groups i should say and
then the most surprising thing here is i
looked at the effect of relative
strength now the fact that the fact that
terrorism is a weapon of the weak is in
almost everything you read about
terrorism it's become essentially a
cliche that terrorism as a weapon of the
weak it turns out nobody actually ever
looked um which was surprising to me but
if you actually measure the strength of
rebel groups and look at which one's
views terrorism and which ones don't
it's not the weakest groups that are
using terrorism there's absolutely no
evidence for that in fact with anything
it's stronger groups that are using
terrorism there's not a statistically
significant effect the terrorism is a
weapon of a strong but it is clearly
clearly clearly not a weapon of the weak
again in this context of civil wars so
all of these groups are are somewhat
strong strong enough to launch a
rebellion so that was something that I
sort of found along the way but it's I
think a very interesting finding ok so
then getting back to my original
question about the effectiveness of
terrorism and that in the paper there's
a lot of statistical tables and I'm not
going to put up my multinomial logit you
know stuff here but i'll just give you
kind of a crude look at the at the data
in in some graphs so there are a couple
of things i think this has a laser
pointer and there are a couple things to
notice about this graph in terms of the
outcomes of civil wars the first is that
was my
they're real the first is over here so
the red bars are the chairs rebel groups
and the blue bars are the non terrorists
rebel groups so where we go over there
there are no cases in this timeframe of
full-scale civil wars in which a
terrorist group achieves outright
victory not a one and terrorist groups
are much more likely to last longer to
be ongoing at any given point in the
data but they're less likely to reach an
agreement than our non terrorist groups
and they're more likely to have these
sort of bad outcomes for the rebels
either fizzling out too low act through
low activity or a government victory so
that sits pretty well with a set of
predictions that terrorism will make
Wars last longer but that terrorist
groups will fare less well and then non
terrorist groups I also looked at this
issue of democracy and again this is
kind of a crude look at the data but all
this holds up in the more complicated
sophisticated statistical analysis so
this is the terrorist groups fighting
democracies versus non democracies and
here I've just collapsed the category so
this is success here defined as either
reaching an agreement or outright
victory there are no outright victories
here as we saw before so this is really
whether groups are achieving a political
settlement and they're more likely to do
so against democracies than against non
democracies and then if we compare that
to the the non terrorist groups here non
terrace groups are actually more
effective against non democracies than
against democracies but again you see
that the success rate for the non
terrorist groups is higher than it is
for the terrorists rebel groups how am i
doing for time and so and just just kind
of summarize the findings of of all of
this wars in which rebels use terrorism
they do last longer and but terraced
rebel groups are extremely unlikely in
fact in this data they never win
outright they're less likely to get
through the second best outcome from the
perspective of a rebel group of a
negotiated agreement that involves
concessions to their side and they are
more effective or less ineffective
against democracies than against non
democracies but overall
rebel groups generally fare quite a bit
worse than non terrorists rebel groups
now again as I keep repeating this is in
the context of civil wars so what if
anything does that tell us about
al-qaeda well for one thing as Kim
mentioned most terrorism takes place in
the context is domestic terrorism local
terrorism the context of civil wars and
so I think part of the point of this
research is to kind of make us broaden
our perspective a little bit to think
about not just the terrorism that
affected us here in New York in the
United States 10 years ago but the
terrorism that affects most people
around the world is this type of
terrorism this type of terrorism is
quite ineffective how well this
translates over to the effectiveness of
transnational terrorism is something my
research can't speak to directly because
I don't have a set of comparable
transnational non terrorist groups to
compare them to but I think a lot of the
logic of this about though the reasons
that terrorism is ineffective spillover
essentially that the issues especially
about undermining legitimacy and
undermining political support I think
translate to transnational terrorism as
well as to domestic terrorism but again
this is sort of my theoretical
speculation more than my empirical hard
data because we don't have a comparison
group that allows us to make that
comparison empirically so I will just
conclude by saying that I think what
this project can do is revived
introducing variation buy by introducing
a control group of a group of relatively
comparable assets of rebel organizations
who choose not to use terrorism that
allows us to shed light on two very
important policy relevant questions that
have not been particularly well
addressed in the terrorism literature
because the terrorism literature is so
focused only on the terrorist groups and
not at these other groups and so the
first is where does charism occur which
as I mentioned I kind of looked at kind
of on the way to getting to my main
question but some of the most surprising
findings are there and then the question
of whether terrorism work so on the
first question and this research and
calls into question a lot of a
conventional and popular wisdom
particularly the finder
cliche that terrorism is a weapon of the
weak but also popular impression that
terrorism is associated with Islam and I
should also I should have said this
probably at the outset this is ongoing
research and findings are somewhat
preliminary but these findings are
holding up as I'm as I'm continuing
through and then on the question that I
started with just terrorism work is it
effective to terrorists win the short
answer is no thanks
you